hello hello and welcome back to our live
stream in the st. Louis chess club it's
gonna be a little bit different today I
know you were probably expecting a Mon I
think he'll be joining us soon hopefully
but for the moment I will be filling in
of course my name is Caleb Denby and
you've seen quite a lot of me over the
past couple days on this channel but
today were gonna be playing on chess
calm and to spice things up a little bit
I'm gonna be risking my own rating
points today no club account this is
this is my personal chess comm account
and if I lose then it was those are my
rating points that I'm not getting back
so uh let's just go for it here I'm just
gonna start off with a random seek and
you can see my username there is a llama
Lord so if you do want to send me a
challenge you're more than welcome to
you'll just have to find that account on
chests Commons go ahead and and give me
a give me a snap challenge this guy is
offering me draws it's very strange
I might accept there you go game to draw
I knew I could do it plus one for me I'm
the greatest thing come ons actually
stuck teaching a class for the moment
but should be over soon should be over
soon and he'll hop right on over for you
guys but so yeah like I said you you're
gonna have to make do with just me for
the moment
all right
really though it's it's a risky day
because I don't know if I can maintain
this rating for too long if I'm
accepting challenges and streaming the
whole time but so we'll see if maybe I
can get it up to 2,400 or down to 2200
one of the two will probably happen by
the end of the stream or maybe I'll just
stay stagnant all right
are you 86 let's do it caro-kann no joke
openings today cuz like I said this is
my rating I've worked hard for it I
don't intend to give it up so no three
night checkmates no no funny business we
are serious chess players today and
we're just breaking in the center as
you're meant to do now waiting around
for anything to happen to me
let's see I guess I'm gonna trade
because trading makes my life easier in
the cow he can take care and maybe the
spawn structure is good for him but it
allows me to trade the Queens and kind
of set up a double attack here so he's
gonna have some problems this pawn here
is only really so dangerous when like
this queen is like aiming at your king
and maybe there's a couple nights on the
board and a couple bishops with just one
night sure it might land on d6 but I can
probably just trade one of my pieces for
it and end up okay so he's probably
trying to play f5 I'm just gonna plan on
taking it I'll probably move this knight
and trade off some more pieces I'm up
upon so I don't see why not
this guy's seems very willing to trade
with me which is very pleasant to see I
might be winning another pond now I
might not be more importantly I might be
able to trade more pieces which is
really my goal in life here
a knight c5 is actually kind of awkward
for me hmm here takes there a five there
a six there seven I resigned I guess
I'll bring my king in
I'll keep bringing my king in hopefully
only nothing terrible happens to me
along the way
says you can't challenge me who are my
settings messed up my settings might be
messed up I'll have to take a look at
that make sure you guys can send me
challenges but yeah this is going to be
like a normal stream pretty much you can
just send me a challenge on this account
instead of the club account and on chess
comm instead of lis chests but other
than that totally the same I'll be
playing you guys rated games three plus
those great one plus those great 5 plus
though is ok increment is the worst
but if press don't play three plus two
hmm so I have a couple options here I
can bring my king this way and like take
this guy but then I probably lose all
these puns I can bring my king this way
this looks more interesting I'll give
this a shot I just have to be careful
not to like hang any Forks you know like
for example Knight c4 would win the game
if it was legal so I just have to not
allow things like that to happen to me I
might have chosen the wrong direction to
move my king and because the way he's
playing it it's just like I'm down a
piece basically but I don't think I
should be losing or anything just yet
after Knight c7 I might be probably
shouldn't have allowed such things okay
you didn't play it I think I'm gonna
accept a feat here and bring my king
back over to the correct side of the
board
should just be a draw I can take this
pond with my king take the other pond
with my knight and cut all today call it
a day
so if g6 I have a 97 check so he avoided
playing g6 for a moment should be safe
to play this move I think g6 just King
g7
I need to turn my treble down watching
this guy is my voice really so high is
it really so high I don't know
oops okay
hopefully this is a drill I think it's a
job all right we did it
why is the game not over I'm confused
do I win if I if he Flags here that'd be
sick hopefully that's true oh god don't
take my name no it's a draw
why didn't the game end I'm confused
whoa it's a Mont Hambleton yeah it says
it's a draw I mean so what I think
happened was late made it illegal so
they don't automatically end the game
but but for some reason if you flag if
you flag they use the other rules which
is why this was a draw but that's
confusing because now like what if I get
this position for example I would have
please don't do that all right here we
go I'm struggling here I'm trying to
construct a checkmate
yeah yeah don't worry about it it's fine
it come join i'm joined just the normal
threats of violence that you would
expect seamless just close okay I really
can't construct this checkmate position
but what if it was like mate in one and
then I can just let my time right now
that's what I'm trying to ask and also
it seems very difficult to construct
this checkmate is it actually possible
I'm confused because the night covers
too many squares or something
I mean you can do it with a bishop and
you can do it with a rook but with a
knight it seems like I can't lose the
right amount of Tempe to make this legal
right cuz when I have this position okay
here we go
okay I've got it now I've got it now
there you go so if I had this position
or something then mate would be legal
but you know I can bought my time right
now or something I don't know
it's a very edge case scenario but it's
kind of funny ladies night is tonight
what is in my ear it's a radio so in
case like the building catches on fire
someone can talk to me and tell me to
leave with that in mind I don't have any
chat oh I have tons of challenges
apparently all right we'll play this
vampire chicken guy
I heard he smells bad and nobody likes
them but it's unconfirmed just rumors
I've heard what color are my socks they
are brown today brown socks
he just to flag yeah it's pretty easy
you just move fast and then it's fine
you just do it
uh I wish I knew in my own opening
better but I don't I'm just gonna play
f3 here and hope for the best
probably I'm supposed to insert Queen c2
but I didn't know play king h1 no I'm
gonna go here yeah that's what I'm gonna
do
yeah we see 96 now maybe I'm gonna bring
my Bishop all the way all the way back
into this nice little cubbyhole on f2
here cover some dark squares that I
don't have covered so he just pushes c4
which makes me put my Bishop on some
awkward squares but it also lets me play
efore with more ease Oh see I can play E
for here it's kind of what I wanted to
do can also play a four kind of slow
down this b5 idea can also play b3 b3
looks kind of interesting maybe a four
followed by B 3 B 3 followed by a four
I'm gonna start with a four
I don't really understand the question
about the caro-kann good through e5 or
it can be dangerous for d4 well you
can't actually play the caro-kann
against d4 it's strictly an opening to
be played against one pawn on e4 so
we're just trying to break up this pawn
here on c4 they could do something
awkward that it doesn't want to do you
know and capture here feels like some
tactics should be coming the screens a
little awkwardly placed some Knight
takes d5 ideas some 94 ideas as well
yeah I'm actually just going to let's
see play Queen to d2 I think and then
it's pretty annoying for black to find a
square to put this Queen on because
otherwise why is someone knowing
Discovery's some annoying 95s and maybe
the Queen's getting stuck
gonna play Nyepi five anyways I think
looks pretty good I'm a couple couple
loose squares here a couple forks maybe
do I always follow imbalances I don't
really think too much about you know I
don't like go through a list in my head
of imbalances when I'm evaluating
position but it can be a useful tool to
think about physicians it's an
interesting move
wait night see seven here and maybe a
winsome material but I'll be giving up a
lot of squares around my king after
night to xh3
feel like I just don't want to allow any
of it and I'll just take on c8 here
they'll like my positions good enough
that I can just get away with playing
simply
so he moved his work back into this
little idea here he's probably planning
night age three if I go here but I don't
think it actually works as well as
Knight f3 I don't believe is quite
working so let's calculate Knight c7
Knight f3 g f3 this should be three
takes takes takes takes and I don't have
more pieces I do have more pieces I do
have more pieces let's do it check
there should be five next dude anyways
when in doubt just save your pieces when
they're attacked especially in time
pressure no reason to get all fancy just
because the clocks are low he's going to
check me I know Jonathan he likes to
give check alright
you missed the check obviously if he had
seen it he would have played it
his work was hanging there I missed it
ah no time we have lost two jonathan
strands disaster I couldn't find mate
and I slowed down trying to find it
couldn't find mate with the rook net
combo and I spent all my time
calculating Knight takes F 3 when I knew
it was winning I should just wait next
e7 immediately instead of wasting 2/3 of
my time let's see where's the checkmate
at where is it it's tough because I
don't have a Jeep on to help Corral this
King what the GT pond it'd be a lot
easier but you know such pawn exists oh
well moving along no one seems to be
challenging me I had a couple but now
they've all gone away I'll try bullet
game see how I do
hey I saw mom's face on here see look it
isn't a Mont Hambleton stream we
wouldn't lie to you
this was three plus so all right I've
got a challenge and it looks like I'm
not gonna find a bullet kin so I'll
accept I've played one you for just for
fun
ha don't forget tonight is the night for
ladies night at 8 p.m. I believe the
first schedule is to be trusted
be sure to tune in check it out should
be a lot of fun
okay I don't know so much about the
Sicilian dragon maybe I was supposed to
play some Bishop c4 move to stop d5 here
I don't really know when a5 has been
played feels like I should just push all
my pawns forward now and try to win the
game maybe it's better to take the time
to play king b1 kidding me b1 seems like
a professional move I'm gonna play it
move my mouse cursor here and read the
chat rookie it's been played I think
he's going to try to come checkmate me
as one usually does in the Sicilian
Dragon I don't think this move makes a
threat this is why I put my king gonna
be one it controls the square a little
bit better what's happening at 8 a
ladies night stream I wish I could
remember who was hosting it tonight I
want to say it's gonna be Emily Trask
along with some of the ladies from our
weekly ladies night class hopefully so
he thinks if I'm gonna take then he's
gonna take care and then he's gonna take
here and then he's gonna take care but I
think I throw in this move and then that
doesn't happen to me
and now I can take I think so now I have
more pieces which is usually a good
thing in chess
sometimes it's a bad thing but usually
it's a good thing probably I just want
to start using this Bishop to help out
somehow maybe I want to save this Bishop
yeah I think so it'd be nice to get rid
of this guy in exchange for this guy
because this guy's pretty good and this
guy is that he's alright
but this guy's pretty good be able play
Bishop h6 here play like I don't know
Queenie to maybe kick this night out oh
he's letting me trade I don't think this
is a good decision
I Spy Danny Machuca looking around any
word on our our house today he's coming
okay
so if you heard that correctly Amon is
fueling up for his stream today and then
he'll be down here shortly
no it's gone down it has gone down
started off around 2345 down to 23 32
I think I'm I've got good chances to win
this one though good chances
oh man message retracted I want to know
what that guy said I did not
I got flagged yes very shameful stuff
but the stream moves on why didn't he
take the pawn on f3 and for Curie Rux
I believe his queen was attacked so he
did not have the chance to do such
things if his Queen was not attacked
maybe that would have been good so I'm a
puppy it's just gonna open up the Kings
side here Jack made him and the game
usually a good plan so I can take on g6
or I can play h6 here h6 is really good
for me if he takes it but the thing
about chess is you know captures aren't
forced so maybe just king h7 for there
for him there would have been fun
yeah I'm not quite good enough to get
any any norms I'm not even a national
master yet so one thing at a time one
thing at a time I haven't been playing
too much tournament chess lately it's I
don't know it's it's grueling stuff you
know takes a lot out of you let's see
where's the funniest check they have so
this is meeting two but is there
anything better anything better and I
lose my queen some funny way and mate
with the Knights can i hmm I'm gonna
start with this
all right I guess I'll just throw in
this one and then play Queen f5 that's
the best I can do
I tried it's my least favorite opening
to play against let's see huh I don't
really know actually um I don't really
like playing against this old Benoni
stuff because it feels like it should be
winning for white but I usually find a
way to mess it up let's see what else
are certain lines in the nihms oh I
heard for me to deal with but other than
that most things are alright let's take
a look at these challenges here we've
got every fish nose go ahead and play
that guy see how I do
what's better than mate fancier mates
where you lose pieces along the way what
else what else would you want to do
where is a mon he's on his way he's on
his way like I said he's just fueling up
a little bit getting some some food
getting some food so he can keep you
guys a good stream I think got a
classical King's Indian here don't know
how I got myself into this mess Bishop
III
I don't know this move quite so well
it's the star of the show he has arrived
welcome come on he's probably no no no
you can't put that on me I was I was in
the basement all day yesterday I'm on
alright help me win this game you don't
have a mic though so yeah you want to
grab this I'm just talking to it maybe
or clip it on it's up to you
this looks pretty good for me I feel
like this should be pretty good for me I
have a nice bishop I have another bishop
which can't really go anywhere but they
can dream think you had a nice position
yeah I concur
I'm feeling good just gonna play Queen
e7 maybe play Bishop e6 next I don't
really care too much about this fun cuz
I can get this pawn and then d5 isn't
quite such a stronghold this is rather
sensual they have a candle here yeah
it's nice it's it's for when it smells
very bad which is quite often as we are
located underneath a greasy diner oh
great I get to chat yeah you're in there
we're not signed in though so you can
actually say anything but I don't want
to talk to these plebs right right
Caleb looks like a Mon pre-party Rock
sure ma never did any any party rockin
no but some dancing for sure yes
this is great so your jam on Hambleton
yes and friends that's good I like being
the friend yeah there's a bit of a meme
going around where it's I'm playing with
a non friend and that's just his name
let's see if that one actually catches
on mm-hmm
first words this is rather sensual you
know just felt like I was walking into
that it's you know like a planned it's a
very intimate scenario it is it is
should win somehow now right I don't
know I don't really get it I think I've
ruined many many things he's trading off
your good Bishop it's like he
understands chess or something I don't
appreciate such things right oh I guess
this isn't checkmate it's close though
it looks good it's pretty close to
checkmate maybe I'll take with the rook
and surprise everybody maybe I won't
take it at all I'd be a shocker don't
think I want to take it at all I got
people congratulating me on my new house
this is not the not the place I expected
these type of comments that is quite
strange thanks no no you had a new house
semi new but we released a house tour so
people got glimpse inside that stand mmm
that was a good move I wish I could play
good move shame
let me Adam let me do it
I better not play wreck f7 we considered
it decided I better not
let's hope he doesn't do that move
it's game could've gone better I'm not
gonna lie
Jack
got a lot of chances here I feel
not letting me put a hero in a mating
net I can't believe it it's not even
that was he so strong can't discuss it
wow you found the mate all right this
guy's a beast I better get out of here
so we can start winning some games how
have you done today uh very poorly
I beat a 1500 but lost to a couple a
couple 21 hundreds maybe a 2000 along
the way I'm gonna go ahead and log out
here
Oh got you hop in here sure I'm probably
gonna have to switch mics here yes we
lacrosse yes sorry Danny can make it so
this doesn't sound terrible
this off to you
it's just gonna be me in a candle I
would love that
all right
you're gonna log in here
okay
good no one knows my password yes
okay
there we go well I gotta get this screen
angled so I got the chat with me to
forget this candle lit I mean this is a
real sensual environment here okay I
think I got the board up here I don't
know what kind of what kind of setup
we're doing here
so I don't really know if the board
looks looks good like this but I think
this was how Caleb had it
sure sure thing okay play the people now
I imagine when they say play the people
that they don't mean the people on chest
calm they mean the people in the chat
play the people in the chat so I'm gonna
assume that this is where I invite you
guys to send me a challenge and and play
me now if those don't roll in I'm very
very happy to to just play some games
see who's logged on but yeah my name is
KNVB on chess calm so you guys are
welcome to send me a challenge here okay
now we got a few challenges
crazy k-11
let's go first game of the day I had to
start with a three-digit rating because
I'm just not warmed up clearly clearly
okay we're gonna in a wide variety of
challenges this is great so if you guys
have a chest Ofcom account now people
slamming doors on me if you guys have a
chest calm account then you can send me
a challenge that will work perfectly
KNVB very easy name to remember
crazy que llevan here's got a pretty
good position I have to say I mean he's
doing nothing wrong which is why I'm
gonna trade pieces with him I don't
trust him
this guy's a beast this guy is a real
beast okay got some 1600 1700 even got
some 2020 100's
play without a queen okay I did that so
we're doing right now I'm playing
without a queen live on stream let's
hope I win let's see what my success
rate is without my queen
okay reasonable move I mean my opponents
playing well crazy crazy crazy guy
mm-hmm develop my bishop thank you
so I'll probably want to get a Rokon the
C file I'm actually really happy to see
b4 here because now now he just made the
c3 pawn week
mic sounds good guys I'm not saying
anything too important so I mean you
know you're not missing out on much
that's the that's the good part about
bringing the rope to c8 probably play
King d7 yeah I think I'll play I could
play a six I could also just leave leave
it there but I'll play a six to keep my
Bishop on this diagonal maybe h4 rook c8
he should have a queen and I don't well
you didn't specify
you said sacrifice the Queen so I
sacrificed it for his queen maybe
another game I'll be happy to play with
Queen odds I'd be happy to play the
Queen odds okay let's do the move I was
talking about rook to c8 next I want to
play maybe Brooke c4 and occupy these
light squares in d7 and rook c8 coming
next
also h4 is a move after age four he
wants to play g4 and hit my knight
that's why I put my rook there as well
so pretty pretty useful pretty useful
move
what's gonna happen here Crazy's talking
to me in chat says no see file for you
I'm gonna send them an unhappy face will
let them know that that makes me unhappy
no see file for me
now I have some ideas here guys take
take let's remember that's a pin rook g4
and I hit the bishop and hit the Jeep on
taking advantage of that pin from a7 so
I actually have some very devious
intentions here be quiet don't tell him
don't let him know what I'm up to
okay he played this move which is nice
because now I can swing my rook over and
just take on h2 and then f2 is gonna
hang after rook h2 I think it's a nice
position so you see that rook on c4 is a
hero not only was he on the C foul but
you can switch over to the H file right
away yeah exactly no I agree my opponent
is playing very very well for 800 841 I
mean
he's playing much better than that so
this makes a lot of sense
I could also try to take this pawn but
after he takes back he's threatening
rook c8 so I would have to play King d7
that doesn't look like a pretty good
move but I think I think I can start
with this so I'll take this pawn king d7
I want to play
maybe Bishop takes d4 he's playing very
well
what time do I play I mean it doesn't
doesn't matter to me and honestly but
let's say less than let's say less than
five minutes to start off okay let's
trade one pair of rooks so I'll check
and take and then we'll go whoops get
the King what kind of arrow is that King
be seven that's what I want
King d7 G 6 if rook G 1 and I still have
pressure here and I can play the rook h4
rock h3 to hit some of these weak points
and the position also rook c8 back is
possible
what's my opponent gonna do he's low on
time here getting under a minute so he
plays rook there this is not really a
threat because then the knight would
hang so I'm gonna play this just slow
slow move I have other options I don't
need to play this but g6 is a really
good move to throw in in any position
but I think what I'm gonna do is gonna
put a little bit more pressure on his
position gonna play rook age five and if
you please have four I'm gonna play g5
and I'm really looking to undermine the
pawn on e5 here looking to undermine
that pawn he does this this is what I
was talking about they can't do that
because he's gonna lose a piece and next
I have rook takes e5 so if he takes rook
e5 check and rook takes d5 and we just
clean up we can just clean up here
RUP a piece that should do the trick
that should do the trick uh-huh
and we're threatening Bishop b2 check
winning the rook Oh even better that is
a free rope for me and we're gonna take
all your pawns now mmm-hmm what is the
fastest checkmate
so probably check and I imagine he might
go here no he goes there
well that's unlucky that's unlucky there
I was trying to give a nice fast
checkmate
didn't quite work all right play Bishop
here and we'll just take his pawns he's
gonna lose on time first I won I should
get reading for that and three times
this guy's reading I deserve his points
more than three times is reading hello
Benjamin Simon how you doing today
Oh then I'm doing great seeing you in a
nice nametag like that
not often exactly so well this was my
first game so not him that's all I can
say about that that's all I can say is
that this guy he played very well he's
probably worth more than his reading
yeah but he wasn't he wasn't up to snuff
it was it wasn't enough to take me out
well Godspeed we got the we got the
bullet challenge as well there the 1100
you guys see I'm working my way up I
can't you know I can't just jump to the
heavy hitters I got to warm myself up
first
I gotta warm up first I'll take bullet
challenges blitz challenge just doesn't
matter Knight takes e4 he's he gonna
play it he does play it okay that's
impressive
buddy you are impressive sir I'm
impressed by him guys what do you think
94 is a good move
94 is a good move I mean he's playing
great ok let's play rookie one just
bring this bishop try to attack these
dark squares here that's a mistake I'll
take so far everyone I've played seems
to be worth a lot more than their rating
so I'm convinced that you guys are
really on some sort of mission to take
me out today everyone's on the alts
everyone's got the the sandbag accounts
I see what's going on I see what's going
on I'm predicting a back rank mate of
some sort here it's gotta happen ok
first we play here so we don't get back
rank maybe I mean that'd just be pure
pure embarrassment it's not gonna happen
uh-huh and where's my back rank mate hey
I was looking for a back rank mate now
that's not happening oh it's close not
quite
this guy's real tricky with it you know
all right good game good game
get out the sandbags oh you guys already
have the moat you guys are building a
building a dam I'm quite sure if that
will play Yamato almost expected a
Japanese flag here what's it gonna be
five minute game five minute game are
you here buddy
are you here
now it feels bad
okay and we'll go to the next game all
right we got casually crushing hopefully
he's not casually crushing me okay
we'll play c4 and play d4 next try to
get a more oxy binding position I'm
trying to force him to play a bind even
if he doesn't want to yes okay this is
what I wanted
all right Queen d2 next okay we'll take
here
it depends if he takes a six I mean he's
not really threatening to play b5 his
nights hanging and otherwise I'm also
just covering it with bishops and
knights here so let's play f3 so we stop
him from going Knight g4 which is kind
of annoying next we could play d3 to
protect this pawn so again I'm just able
to sort of cover all my weak points in
the position here and create this really
nice pawn structure the Marazzi pawn
structure so I'll bring this rook over
probably drop my bishop back maybe rook
e1 and Bishop back rook d1 is also
possible he's trying to think more about
this b5 move although at the moment am i
covering it it looks like I am it looks
like I am yeah a 95 can be played here
this is the other sort of typical idea
they take and then you take on e7 first
and then take back so I'll just play
this and I'll see what my opponents get
into I'll see what he's up to here right
so now I take check and then I take this
Queen back and somehow I snuck away with
a pawn there somehow very nice
yeah KNVB is what you can challenge if
you want a game I'm on chess comm here
all right rook c7 let's go
well I don't have to go Knight back but
I could can also play this move just hit
that rook a little annoying here
it's like where does he put that thing
Brooksie five then Bishop d6 and he's
actually running out of squares yeah
probably a Bishop d6 I mean b4 is also
possible but if he takes I don't really
like my doubled pawns there so I think I
prefer to play Bishop d6 and yeah that
rooks actually trapped here mm-hmm
let's take
see what he takes with here I think
probably the pawn takes would have been
the best move now I'll take here I'll
bring that rook to d1 hit that pawn
remember I got the two bishops here plus
I'm up the exchange I had a rook for a
rook for a knight here
okay he wants to take on a to probably
though what I can do is I'll just play
Bishop a5 and if he takes there then
rook c2 is actually gonna trap his
knight on a - and if she goes back then
I'll just bring my Bishop back here this
is a good diagonal I want to trade I'm
up material so why not why not well
probably there's nothing simpler than
just doubling against the weakness okay
yeah and I didn't double with my
Brooklyn c1 by playing rope d2 because
then Bishop h6 looked annoying so we're
not even gonna give that option
I'll take wait f4 gained a little bit
space bring my bishop here and look for
ideas like 'if I've if I've is gonna be
a good move in fact I can just play e5
because again we're utilizing the pin
here
Bishop f3 King f2 we've got this pawn
hanging it's looking pretty good here
for me
casually crushing goodgame glad to see
that a bunch of people are sending their
challenges in I definitely have a little
queue going on here
actually I got a lot of challenges holy
smokes how old smoke s--
you guys are trying to take me down here
okay dharna pick
we didn't play d4 yet today it's time
for d4 mm-hmm yes everyone loves this
opening right everyone likes this
opening the ratings are going up in up
here suddenly we got an 1800 on our
hands it's no easy task Queen b6 and
then c5 and my opponent may already be
in trouble here I mean you can play
queen C aid but rook c1 is generally
pretty uncomfortable Queen d7 there's
Knight f3 coming in with 95 so yeah
already I don't really like blacks
position here and the nice thing is that
when you know when you play Queen b3 and
just hit this pawn it's very tough too
very tough to handle all right he's in
the think tank he's in the think tank
what's he gonna come up with here
there's a lot of ways to defend that
pawn but it's just none of them are very
good none of them are very good
uh-huh c5 he's gonna take
and the thing is here I'm gonna play b4
and I'm gonna play b5 as well and you
can't really stop me from playing this
if you play a six well I get to play b5
anyway so let's do first things first
and keep my bishop in case of them of
like Knight age five let's play the b5
move before he plays a6 and stops us
and we'll see what he wants to do here
but now I got another pond coming up to
be four and I'll probably do something
like this and I'd have three or 92
Bishop on d3 they'll trade it off for
that guy
it's funny I don't think I've done many
streams without music I don't think I've
done many streams without music it's a
very somber feeling just me and my
candle okay probably probably just
develop here
basically I want to take here take back
and play Bishop a6 threatening Bishop d7
forking the rook and the pawn on c6 when
I see a move like this I'm probably
interested in taking it
g4 takes here takes they're not great
because he can take here but what I
could do is I could throw in I could
throw in a different move if I want I
could throw this in first so I think
what I'll do is I'll take here and I'll
actually just do the move that I was
talking about I'll play here and I'll
just threaten Bishop d7 it's a pretty
big threat if you lose this that c6 pawn
he's in trouble he is in trouble in the
meantime this guy can drop back to h2
I've 95 or 92 to either kick that night
out or trade for that night and this is
actually a really big threat you see he
can't play rook b8 which is very very
annoying here
you cannot play this guy without making
a chest calm account that's correct that
seems very logical that seems very
logical to me so yes of course if you
want to play me on chess calm you have
to have a chess calm account
don't know what he's gonna do times
ticking down here buddy okay he takes
I'll take back these double pawns are
not that bad they're actually actually
kind of strengthens my control here
we're playing a three plus two games so
if he plays quickly we can keep playing
here but I'm worried he's gonna flag
yeah he just Flags here unfortunately
but yeah I was just gonna play Bishop
back if I get attacked Bishop b7 seems
like a seems like a good position for me
so thanks for the game let's keep going
here I like the idea of gradually
increasing the ratings but I'm not sure
if I can keep doing it technically this
is a higher rating 18:01 these three
points better three points better
and so peace here let's hope he's here
s-see Carl
feels bad getting stood up by dates
getting stood up by SC Carl it's rough
out here guys it's rough
alright let's play kappa blanka century
it's a five-minute game alright play the
Sicilian
c6
mmm
okay maybe 96 makes sense takes takes I
think I'll play Knight f6 like if he
plays d4 here I mean
kind of depends on what he's gonna do
Knight c3 quenette f6 so if he plays d4
again I'll take it if not he has to
decide how he wants to place his pieces
so okay he's gonna go d4 AB was gonna
take and I think we'll play I could play
Bishop c5 or Bishop before but let's try
this one Bishop before I think he's a
little more theoretical but I'd rather
just play rather play my own thing
Bishop c5 oh he takes that's interesting
I have an option here actually how I
want to take taking with the be pawn is
sort of the most flexible taking with
this pawn though makes a lot of sense
because then I just played five nights
so uh let's try taking this way and
playing an endgame we'll see what he
wants to do because I think my bishop on
this score is quite powerful and E 5 is
met by Knight g4 by the looks of it
okay and now I wanted to play e5 to stop
e5 by him Bishop e6 King e7 and sort of
controlled the D file here and I want to
play on the dark squares I want to play
on the dark squares here okay Bishop e6
always going to be a good move
c4 is unusual yeah it's actually the
move that I play it when I was just
white a couple games ago I played c4
you sort of try to force him or oxy so
here we saw my opponent try to do it but
I don't think I ever allowed him didn't
work out probably as he intended
okay Bishop out let's play King g7 I'm
gonna protect my night and next move I
want to kick his Bishop out with h6
maybe get my rook over to the open file
here okay
kick the bishop important step
very important step
so if he takes King takes there is a
move like Knight to d5 check but I think
I'll just sidestep it it's kind of a
cool-looking move
sort of makes a make sense but I mean he
plays it first I guess it's sort of the
same thing although he gives me okay now
that's basically the same thing I
suppose this isn't really an option
King d6 king d6 just Knight takes well
King d6 Bishop f6 I'm trying to create a
position where maybe I give him a pawn
but I keep my bishops I think that might
be more enjoyable to play for me rather
than the problem is if I take and he boy
he's gonna throw in this move and then
he takes back it's just gonna be like an
opposite Bishop position and not sure
that I'm too interested in playing that
so I'm actually going to see if I can
create a position here where I'm gonna
give up a pawn but I think I have pretty
good compensation so I'm gonna take back
tags now probably what Bishop d4 let's
hit the pawn on B to the next I want to
bring my king back and now he doesn't
have a 95 so we're gonna hit that night
there's no 95 because now my bishops not
hanging now I'll go and grab man should
I grab this pawn does rook e1 maybe we
don't need to do that maybe just a 5
yeah maybe a five play a five try to get
like a four a three ideas if I play a
four then if I ever take always have a
three so I feel like the bishop should
be quite strong here let's play this we
have this little threat and I like
playing with the bishop pair here rather
than rather than like before okay
probably this he has a rerouting that
he's gonna do but let's push this pawn
down the board and I think that pawn is
actually gonna get really scary with
these two bishops here yeah so I figured
that he was gonna do this because he can
put his knight on f5 but I was hoping to
just ignore it so I'm gonna play rook
here he can take me I may actually take
with the pawn trying to decide trying to
decide if that's helpful or not King
takes okay we'll take with the pawn and
see how this works trying to say that
I'm defending a lot of light squares
here and I wanna bring that rook over at
b6 with some some attack on this pawn
here
it's just sort of like defending
everything what a guy what a guy let's
attack this pond just see how he wants
to defend it Bishop back seems like a
reasonable move I'll play rook here and
hit this pawn b3 now I think if I take
it sort of makes his life easier so I'm
gonna push a3 and at least yes to think
about that pawn and in a lot of end
games maybe this rook however I think I
need to be rerouting it's probably done
its job on probably done its job on b4 I
have to say so let's get it out of there
sort of bring it back to civilization
interesting move I'll play here I'll hit
that pawn if you play g3 then I win your
bishop so if you have to play age five
well that's sort of what I want
I'll just rook d3 wow these are like
really really surprisingly accurate
moves because here there's here rook h2
Bishop g2 my Brook is almost getting
trapped or something
that's a little weird
actually after rook age - there's rook
takes d4 and King g1 and my rook is
trapped so that's the next level move
there guys that is a next level move
rook d3 holy smokes
okay we'll bring my rook back if rook b3
I have to play Bishop there I mean this
guy's really coming with the moves takes
and rook there holy cow this guy is very
lethal we got to put our Bishop there I
think
I'm pretty sure we've got to trade a
pair of rooks here it's getting kind of
uncomfortable maintaining the position
so something like bringing the King to
c7 and this guy's just a beast man
I'm what a beast we're playing five
minutes there's no increment no
increment you guys should bring the
bishop back just to force him to play
he didn't play f3 I thought that he was
going to
maybe he'll try to take on the spawn
here and then lose to that but he
doesn't
not quite
right good game those were some of the
nicest moves I've ever seen man rook d3
was like pretty incredible but yeah
five-minute game that's a long time I
don't have a chance to flag you
well-played I suppose that was a pretty
flawless game buddy kappa blanka century
playing like the guy himself that cost
me a bit of rating none of you guys can
give me my rating back feels bad man I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna have to really
farm some people thanks for the thanks
for the game I think we still got a few
challenges coming in here ya know that
I'm you know it was a very accurate game
I have to say kegui from Finland that's
cool get a guy in from Finland thanks
for the challenge hanging out on the
show I'll play you for against you Katie
some funny comments in the chat probably
ones I'm going to refrain from reading
it loud
we'll play the bishop's opening so just
efore Bishop c4 and we'll see what we'll
do next
playing h3 to cover this square I want
to keep my Bishop and long term I have
an idea maybe to play out for butts
I don't think it's wise to rush with
that for because I really give away
Queen age for checks so better I just
focus on developing here you know play
Bishop III see if he wants to take get
my night out Queen d2 and yeah let's see
where he wants to go from there it
should be six okay let's see ninety-two
and I want a Castle kingside next Queen
d2 and f4
I could Castle queenside but I'm not too
sure I want to invite him to sort of
swarm me with his pawns here Queen d2
maybe I'm teasing him like I could play
long castle I don't really plan to I
plan to play short castle but maybe this
move is going to suggest either Queen
Bishop takes h6 or queenside castle so
maybe he'll get scared of one or both of
those
one or both of those hopefully both yep
now I could take with the pawn or the
Queen I'm gonna decide to take with the
pawn because it looks interesting I'm
gonna castle bring a rook to f1 and just
focus on putting pressure on f7 here I'm
actually going to ignore that
I'm gonna let him sort of ruin my pawns
quote-on-quote
but just because it doesn't look good
doesn't mean it isn't good that's
actually my tinder profile just because
I don't look good doesn't mean I'm not
okay yeah double ace later pawns I know
I know you're thinking doesn't look too
great man but I'm looking at putting a
knight on f5 and they don't d5 and
making some progress
let's start by playing rook to d1
Queen D 3G 4 and H III can be played
King G 2 I think I do want to play like
this G 4 idea although he's making me
feel like that's not a good idea alright
let's start with just Knight g3 thinking
about Knight they're also rook takes f6
those kind of sacrifice ideas are very
common I just couldn't play it yet
because I wasn't ready to control the f5
square so now I'm I'm sort of ready with
one of these two moves or both of them
rook d8 he's looking at maybe playing
the c6 and d5 I could play Knight d5
here I could also play Knight f5
okay let's play Knight d5 see where he
wants to go I still have a good place
for this night so I'm trying to get rid
of that one so that f5 belongs to me
if he takes I should have a really nice
choice between which pawn I want to use
it's normal to try to undo but the
problem is I have two sets of double
pumps so which ones do I undo Bowl it's
good both ways I'm gonna take this way
maybe follow up with efore Knight f5
ideas it depends really where he puts
his Queen I guess yeah if he puts it
there I think I'm gonna take and I'm
probably gonna just play efore so I'm
hitting the h6 pawn this Knight jumps
into f5 and I'm hoping that that just
creates a meeting that here and I think
it does so it can be really
uncomfortable to deal with these sacs
that's why I mentioned it earlier
yeah and he's just getting made it here
Brook g8 is made in one Rick h8 is made
in two Queen h6 Queen g7 so yeah good
game PEGI usually able to get a good
attack there but that rook f6 motif is
very very common very very common all
right
Maddi 22 good luck
naughty 22 yeah mm-hmm sure
hopefully my opponents here this has
happened a lot it feels bad I'm getting
stood up by the chat people aren't here
oh man okay okay
Elliot's good luck hope you're here I'm
just gonna accept a bunch of games and
no one's gonna be around to play them I
mean the challenges haven't been sitting
there that long
this guy's not here either all right
nobody's here
feels bad all right I'm gonna get in
trouble for aborting so many games
that's the thing I'm gonna get punished
for this all right let's go maybe for
Nate dizzle Nate are you here
yay someone's here we'll play the French
just for Nate
yeah the silver Neko maybe you'll be the
last challenge I see your challenge here
so I'll play after this and maybe maybe
that'll be it maybe that'll be it for
our little stream here between 87 see
what Nate wants to do okay sort of a
mainline this b6 is a sideline but
whites plans remain very similar 90 h3
that's it it seems like a very
intelligent move it seems like a move
that he's playing with an intention you
know it doesn't seem like a random move
seems like he's playing it because he
knows it's supposed to be good or
something
okay I will play night here which guards
my pollen and there's no g4 to kick me
out because his queen is occupying that
square so I would love to get a queen
trade I think that would be nice and for
that reason he believes that we should
not have a queen trade Nate
dizzle hmm tricky tricky Queen f3 seems
like a very good move
Nate age 3 in Queen a f3 seemed like
very good move
played with intention by my opponent you
know really looked like he knew what he
was doing there I have to say bring my
queen back
cleaned up for the stream today I was
doing something before the stream which
I thought it best to clean up for so
yeah I got rid of the old got rid of the
old beard there again these moves are
coming in they're flying in c4 it
doesn't care about this I mean some of
the moves that these guys are coming
with real scary real scary if you take
so I was thinking maybe I take on d4 but
these variations are not not clear-cut
at all so we'll see what that one does
take so I want to take on d4 maybe
follow up with something like c5
expecting one of these rather strong
moves or maybe this one is the stronger
one who knows I could take here and then
the knight would take I'm not sure if I
really like that position or nots
[Music]
hmm
I could just just move my queen like
Queen d7 but okay I'm running into some
stuff here I mean these moves that are
coming in are real powerful real
powerhouse moves
Wow these are strong moves man these are
strong moves I mean you guys are really
bringing out the the accuracy today I
have to say some of these 1600s
at least 2000s you guys were strong man
like a thousand points higher rated than
this guy it doesn't feel like it though
let me tell you that it does not feel
like it
okay night there again knots big fan of
high position
have to move this night if it gets
attacked I mean jeez what's happening
what's happening you guys are crazy good
today
try to play c5 I guess Wow oh man
he's calculating some nasty moves if
night be three there's queen a4 jeez I
mean you guys are playing some real real
real good chess so I'm gonna give up a
piece here you can see if I can flag him
because you guys are playing some
massively accurate chess right now the
only chance is to flag him here he's
playing way too accurate
so look there oh my goodness what a move
eventually though guys he is going to
run out of time he's gonna play some
very inaccurate moves coming up mark my
words
uh-huh okay I mean guys you these are
some of the most accurate chess games
I've ever seen
I can't compete I got 1600s playing
perfect chess 1600s playing perfect
chess I got 2,100 is playing perfect
chess will play silver Nico probably be
the last game of the stream but I just
came on here I'm just getting abused I'm
playing some of the strongest chat I've
ever seen seven I have for tonight of
six work so it takes takes well I could
play King d7 maybe maybe I play King d7
and try to run because I'm sure well
first of all let me put it this way if
my opponent played Knight f6 I would
assume that it works let me say that so
if you play Knight f6 I might have just
resigned on the spot like for fear of
just being massively embarrassed oh they
really are dmg they really are but I
mean you know you gotta you got to
battle them off you really got to fight
them off
okay so we're gonna handle this move by
bringing the knight back to d7
and playing Bishop e7 so he goes here
and I think I'm gonna bring my knight a6
try to play like a four okay so we'll
hit this pawn
I think he's gonna play c3 I'll make
sure to play h6 so I can save my bishop
play Bishop e7 next maybe a four yeah so
this is important that's why I played
that to keep my Bishop I could have
actually played Bishop d3 which I
neglected to do for a few moves in a row
now actually that's a little little poor
of me but I think the main reason I can
tell you guys why I didn't play Bishop
d3
is the last couple games have
conditioned me to believe that my
opponents are not capable of mistakes so
you can tell I'm clearly not on the
lookout for anything that remotely works
for me
so that means silver Nico almost got
away with it there because the chat has
conditioned me not to play good moves
okay attacking both of these he could
have actually defended both of them with
a move like Queen e2 now he drops this
pawn and I think after rook b1 it takes
rook b7 I have an IC 5 which Forks these
two things that should probably win the
only reason it doesn't win is it was
actually a very nice move there Queen b1
which protects his rook and hits my
queen
so I would have probably chosen a
different move there now I'm threatening
these two pawns again
okay Queen take see-through check now a
Knight takes e5 and I'm sort of just
cleaning up pawns here well silver Nico
could have kept playing could have kept
playing the reason I would always
suggest to keep playing is because I
keep playing against some of the 1600s
who play very well against me and you
can be sure that I'm gonna make more
mistakes than they are so it's probably
in your best interest to keep playing
because there's no way I can put
together the same caliber of chess that
some of the chat was able to deliver
today so I would say keep playing but
thanks for the game anyway
thanks for the game thanks for waiting
your turn
yeah I guess well I guess what maybe
ended off ended off there for today that
was we got a we got a good number of
games in actually I'm not sure how many
but you know although I feel the average
rating might have been about 1600 the
average the average level was about 2600
so it's actually a fairly competitive
day for me and thanks for for coming out
tuning in we had over 150 people
watching so thanks for coming out to
play the people me I'm the people thanks
for playing me and Caleb earlier who was
holding down the stream so yeah I think
well maybe call it there guys but I had
fun thanks for tuning in being in the
chat and sending some challenges jeez to
those who got to play and hopefully see
you guys again sometime but for now I'll
I'll land it off here and again thanks
for coming out and supporting take care
guys